welcome back to peterborough censor this
is inside the 1922 committee room this
is where it's all happening tonight the
359 conservative mps have now registered
their vote as to whether they have
confidence in boris johnson that number
includes boris johnson himself who had
to decide whether he had confidence in
himself and to join now by its capable
former leader liberal democrats great to
see you
looking i have to say extremely rested
tanned
full of energy is that what happens
after you stop being a leader yeah
retirement
what do you make of all this what's
going to happen do you think in terms of
well i'm i'm a bit i'm unfashioned by my
viewers i i think boris will win
probably and i suspect his supporters
brought this division on they could have
waited a few weeks
but now it's probably the best time to
have it there's some bad news coming
down the road
there was momentum building up against
him so have the vote now take it on
and then he's got a year's grace
probably um and you know we know he's
he's a mouth you know he's a politically
very clever guy great communication
skills
he can possibly turn it around well he's
the ultimate slippery yeah
every time you think something's gonna
stick to him off his slides and he just
barrels on which in a way is a political
skill no i would would have some money
on him actually would you yeah
interesting grace i mean he could he
could just come through this stronger
than ever because of course if he comes
through with a reasonable majority he'll
claim complete vindication he'll say
party gate is now officially over the
rebels have tried they will have to back
off they're going to have to you know
just suck it up for at least a year
unless they change the rules which i
think is unlikely so boris would live to
find another day that could happen it
could and i think boris himself has
learned that he can basically come
through almost anything he can like he
can get attacked he can come through
scandals and survive um i think partly
that probably stems back to his
upbringing you don't go to eaton and
oxbridge and come through the british
establishment without knowing a little
something about how to kind of come
through scandals but i also think it is
just the fact that he has come through
so many now he seemed able to lie
throughout his career he seemed able to
i mean really if you look back over the
last several years of the conservative
party of this government it's not just
been the party gate scandal we've had
the green cell scandal which in my
opinion was far far worse it exposed
kind of corruption at the heart of the
british state you had all this stuff
about his wallpapers you had everything
that was going on during um the pandemic
you've got now the massive cost of
living crisis which really should be
what we're talking about and he has just
been able to basically cast all of this
off and consistently
you basically start culture wars throw
you know new stories onto the table
throw dead meat to journalists and say
let's fight about something rather than
talking about the issues that matter and
it could work again isabel i mean is he
basically our version of donald trump
now where truth isn't that important to
his political success because people
factor in
that he's a you know that he's pretty
loose and free with it well that's sort
of what sharon was saying earlier and
but i think there's scales of lying
isn't there and you know this man is a
pathological liar and at some point i
think the voters become repelled by that
on the issue of the rules
the possibility of them being changed
that's not as distant as you might think
there are
an elections elections coming up for the
1922 committee they actually have it in
their gift to change the rules so that
year that he's supposedly saved for come
september that might not look quite so
okay
let's go to talk tv's political editor
kate mccann again kate uh we're
literally maybe four or five minutes
away now from getting this result are
you getting any more feeling
about where it may go or are we all
literally in the dark here
well everybody is literally in the dark
because the only person who knows is the
gray and brady who's the chair of the
1922 committee my understanding is that
he was going to drop the prime minister
a line just before he announces that
result at nine o'clock so the pm can be
aware of exactly what's happening i
think it's fair to say as harry was
saying to you just before piers it's
fairly jittery here things have got a
bit louder people have started to come
to camera points to react to that vote
but you know number 10 sources saying
that the reaction of deanna davison we
were talking about her earlier on the
red hall mp who's
said tonight that she is going to vote
against the prime minister she's going
to vote no confidence that that was a
bit of a wobbly moment that that has
worried them slightly they are now very
concerned about what other mps might do
other so-called quiet mps who haven't
been as public about their views they
thought they could rely on her clearly
they couldn't and may well be more the
same they're saying for what it's worth
that are two-thirds results so
two-thirds of the party backing the
prime minister would be a pretty good
result for them but also admitting
behind the scenes that anything
lower than that any less than two-thirds
of mps backing the prime minister is
going to look very difficult indeed i
think there are wild ranges when it
comes to how this is going to play out
for him but anything 150 180 is starting
to look quite tricky i mean i've got
vince cable here he's very bullish on
boris he's he's saying that he'd put
money on him surviving and thriving
well look i think i think that's
probably fair i think vince cable's
probably right the prime minister may
well win this vote and he may well go on
to move forward as the leader of the
conservative party as the prime minister
but i think there is a question now
about whether this is the beginning of
the end because remember those two
by-elections loom they are not far away
the promise he made today to his mps in
the 1922 committee i'm a winner i can do
this again if you back me better times
are still to come well if they lose
those two by-elections that's going to
look very difficult and we've been
talking all day long about the fact that
1922 committee rules say if he wins this
vote tonight he's safe for a year well i
wouldn't bet money on that because the
1922 committee earlier this year
discussed changing the rules so you
could have two votes one every six
months they could well do that if they
want to because as i say it's convention
not rules vince cable i mean you're a
betting man and you would bet that he
will survive this and and carry on
but should he it's a different question
no from a national interest point of
view no i mean the reasons you set out
earlier you know you've lost the trust
of the public you've
made laws and not followed them you know
you've treated the public as idiots i
mean i think for the holy see of public
standards and ethics the answer is no
but in terms of the conservative party i
mean he may be the best that they've got
i mean he shouldn't he's holding this
coalition together right but should any
serving prime minister who is fined by
the police
in this country for breaking his own
lockdown rules should any prime minister
survive even that moment no and if you
know from the wider public interest
obviously the answer is no but this is
not what the vote's about i mean they're
choosing the best leader that they can
produce and you know he does hold this
conservative coalition together it's not
it's not at all clear who can do better
what happens if he survives this
and then we discover that secure starm
and angela rayner get fined by the
police
for what they did with the curry and the
beers and they've already pledged to
resign
well he he may well and that actually in
a strange way may help the labour party
i mean stan has done his work he's
detoxified it he's got rid of the
corbynites and they may and there are
quite a few very talented people mainly
women on their front bench who could a
bit more charismatic than he is so
actually that may not be a bad outcome
for labour so it could help the party um
let's we've got six seconds away now
from 9 o'clock we were told to expect
the result at nine o'clock so here's big
ben
right at the heart of our parliamentary
democracy it is
906 seconds and there's nothing come on
say graham brady you've tormented us all
evening where are you man maybe it's a
tie
oh vince cable raising the specter of it
being a tie which would be unthinkable i
have no idea what happens in that
eventuality but the the reality is we're
now watching
live scenes from parliament and the 1922
community we are waiting to hear the
result people are back in this looks
like so graham brady has got his result
and we're about to hear it let's go live
and just listen in good evening
uh i can report as returning officer
uh that 359
ballots were cast
no spoiled ballots
that the vote in favor
of having confidence in boris johnson's
leader was 211 votes and the vote
against was 148 votes
and therefore i can announce that the
parliamentary party does have confidence
[Applause]
well there's the result is 211 in favor
of boris johnson but 148
conservative mps voted against their own
prime minister tonight which i would say
is an incredibly high number let's go to
adam bolton adam your take on that
result
well that's 58
of the votes in favor of boris johnson
uh so that clearly uh is just a little
bit better than mrs thatcher when she
was forced out on 55
but it's considerably worse than theresa
may
who got 66 percent of the votes cast and
remember uh jacob rees-mogg the cabinet
minister now uh said then that that was
not a vote of confidence that she should
resign uh it's also less than john major
got so
this is a bad result uh for boris
johnson of course he lives to fight
another day
and he probably of his predecessors
thatcher major or may is uh more
inclined to try and fight it out
but obviously 148 is bad news i mean we
were hearing earlier on from the boris
johnson camp that they were hoping to
keep the number of rebel mps below
100 well they've
failed by a factor of 50 percent on that
so
what happens next it looks like mr
johnson will struggle on it looks like
uh there's going to be this issue
of uh what happens to kierstama and
angela rayner if they resign that will
clearly put pressure on him uh given his
own behavior then uh we could have those
by-elections and if he loses both of
those uh conservative mps will
appear to have gambled on a loser and of
course at the end of this uh if he's
still there uh once the standards
committee has looked into this there's
the whole question of whether he lied it
to parliament so it looks to me as if
we're going to get the continuing agony
of boris johnson and
it does seem to me that with
you know a third of his party not
backing him more than a third of his
party uh not backing him uh 40 in fact
that uh you know he is heading towards
a very difficult few months and it's
very unlikely that he'll be able to move
on and concentrate on all that
government business his loyalists keep
on telling us about but he will stay
right let's just for recap then so 359
conservative members of parliament voted
tonight and the vote of confidence in
the prime minister here's the result
from sigre and brady i can report as
returning officer
that 359 ballots were cast
no spoiled ballots
that the vote in favor
of having confidence in boris johnson's
theater was 211 votes and the vote
against was 148 votes
and therefore i can announce that the
parliamentary party does have confidence
let's go to vince cable vince i mean i
would say 148 of his own mps varying
against him that's not a good night for
boris johnson surely it's not a good
night except he has survived and and we
know that this very unlike the the
theresa may
dissidents who were united who knew what
they wanted and were were very organized
and committed his opponents in his own
party are very fragmented there's no
clear login
so he has survived and i would expect he
will continuously make maybe bad news
for the country it's i think it's good
news for kirsten murray david i mean
they've they've now because they're
going to go out they've got a wounded
opponent now davey's emerging
the sort of knight in shining armor of
british politics isn't he the only
untouchable it's not been tarnished by
party gate at all well
indeed yeah i mean isabel
give me a snapshot reaction to this
result i think it's the worst possible
result actually for the conservative
party certainly for the country a great
result for the labour party because this
now this agony will go on and on and on
any idea that this has somehow put the
issue to bed is absolutely for the birds
think of all those people that have
publicly come out today within the tory
party for the first time blistering
letters of no confidence you can't take
that away they've put it in writing
that's not going to suddenly kind of
evaporate because there's been some kind
of consensus there isn't a consensus
here it's just a majority and not a good
one at that grace you know it seems to
me if you're using a shipping analogy
the boat has been hold
and we're just not quite sure how
quickly it's going to
tumble to the bottom of the ocean yeah i
mean i think as i said before boris
could quite easily more easily but he
could conceivably stumble through this
he could protect himself he could
basically just carry on as though
nothing has happened get to the point of
the next election um be confident in the
fact that there's no clear successor to
replace him that as vince was saying
that his opponents are not united
whether or not this does actually end up
being good for the labour party is i
think a big question here because we're
going to have effectively several years
of non-government it's unlike all the
news is going to be uh confined to
what's going on within the tory party
and then the stuff that they chuck out
to keep us busy chatting whilst they go
about their business the question is can
labour construct a narrative about where
we should be going because kirsten has
not done that effectively thus far so
unless he can actually say what should
we be doing right now where should we be
going as a country how should we be
solving the cost of living crisis then
it's not actually going to benefit labor
we could end up going back to a
situation like we had before 2018 of
just hung parliaments and constant kind
of procedural i mean if you are labor
though you might be thinking to
yourselves let's just keep boris there
because that might be the best chance we
ever win in the election uh joining me
again is talk to me political editor
kate mccann who's with tory mp and
forest supporter mike wood
i am piers i have to add just on those
numbers you're having a really
interesting chat there with adam about
them remember there were around 174
people on the payroll so who essentially
paid or had an advantage to backing
boris johnson if you take a look at
those numbers with the number who have
eventually supported him that only is
around 35 additional that's not great
for the party so as you say let's ask
mike wood about that because he is here
with me mike you obviously do support
the prime minister you can't be very
happy with these numbers are you well i
think i said before you that beforehand
that i thought that anything more than
210 would be a solid result 211 is
obviously in line with that it's
majority the party will say that in
order to replace a leader you need a
majority voting to have no confidence
instead it's a clear majority saying
that they have confidence in boris
johnson to remain leader of the
conservative party and now he does need
to
get back to focusing on those important
issues facing the country and the world
at home it's a pretty whopping number
though it's well over a third higher
than most people expected the party
we're saying this morning they wanted to
keep it under 100 rebels they haven't
managed that by a long shot how on earth
is boris johnson going to bring people
back together now well kate you you were
here at the time of the last leadership
election you remember on that fifth
ballot when it was blindingly obvious
that boris johnson was going to be in
the final two he still only got 51
percent of conservative mps he got 160
conservative mps voting for him in that
fifth ballot at a time when he was
clearly going to be in the
final two
so he's he's built there's a further 51
who've supported him tonight on top of
the numbers
the prime minister says that he's had a
good pandemic he's made all the big
calls right it's not really great to
only have added that number of mps and
when over a third of your own party
still think he's the wrong man for the
job
well no i i think it's clearly over over
half of voted that they want him to
remain as leader of the conservative
party anders and as prime minister there
are really big issues facing the country
at the moment that go well beyond some
of the issues that have obviously been
raised as uh over the last few weeks we
need the prime minister to be supporting
people with the cost of living as he has
been doing we need him to be continuing
to lead the western world in resisting
russian aggression in ukraine and we
need him to be focusing on helping our
businesses our schools and our nhs to
rebuild after the covid pandemic that's
the important work all the things that
we're elected to do in december 2019 we
need to build on that progress remind
people why they voted for a conservative
government with a clear majority and i
know that boris johnson is the best
leader of the conservative party to
deliver on that and the best person to
lead the country going forward mike wood
thank you very much there you go pierce
that's the argument of conservative mps
tonight mike wood at pps there now uh
producer victoria is just going to nip
in and get anne marie travailian who is
the trade secretary mike's up so uh if
you want to have a quick chat to her
because what's really interesting now is
this number of mps this this scale that
was above what the party was really
hoping to see 148
that means that the next couple of days
and the next couple of weeks are going
to be really difficult for the prime
minister we saw a hint of that today he
was talking in the 1922 committee about
a potential announcement on tax cuts
about focusing on policy going forward
but i think things are going to get very
difficult for him now and anna marie
javelin joins us here
anne marie de valiant you are the trade
secretary you're in boris johnson's
cabinet
how does it feel tonight to know that
that many of your own mps don't support
him
so uh i'm glad that we are the other
side of the vote i know that the prime
minister spent all day listening to
those police who had those concerns and
he will have heard from them where those
areas of policy were that they feel he
needs to focus on and as you say there
are some really big areas of policy that
we want to drive forwards both in
the energy revolution infrastructure
investment really importantly tackling
the cost of living crisis and making
sure that we bring forward policies that
make a difference to all our
constituents day in day out there is so
much to do obviously we were elected on
a very broad manifesto in 2019 the
challenges of covid and uh the emergency
situation that we have seen within the
prime minister led not only the uk and
delivering a vaccine but the world in
finding solutions demonstrating that he
has that incredible capacity to push
through in really hard situations i know
that tomorrow morning he will be drawing
together all those thoughts and really
putting forward a package of measures
and policy direction which are going to
help the uk really move forwards at pace
i'm really excited so does that mean tax
cuts next week then i wouldn't dare
speak on behalf of the chancellor's gate
you know that would be a an absolutely
death sentence for anybody but i hope
very much that we will see
the treasury looking across the piece
and broadly forwards how we can drive
forward what is a conservative a clear
conservative policy framework always
which is to make sure that we leave as
much of our hard-earned cash in the
pockets of those who learned it that's
always been a concern philosophy and we
need to make sure that we pay down some
of the costs we've had to pick up
through kobe but i know that the
chancellor prime minister will want to
drive that forwards in due course i know
that you're here in support of the prime
minister i know that you're going to say
that he's doing the best job and that he
can move forward from this but the
reality is going to be really really
difficult do you honestly believe that
boris johnson can bring this fractured
party back together and fight the next
election
yes i really do because he has always
demonstrated that when we're in really
difficult circumstances where there are
many many competing forces he has an
extraordinary clarity uh he has an
ambition he has a bold perspective and
he has a confidence in the british
people which is reciprocated from them
and i know that going forwards now this
is past this voces pass he will want to
pick all that up and drive forward make
sure that we are delivering for all
those who voted for us back in 2019. and
marie trevelyan thank you so much for
joining us tonight
sophia is interesting to hear the views
of the cabinet and the fact that anne
marie cherellian is saying now that
boris johnson has the confidence of the
country but he doesn't necessarily have
the confidence of all of his mps i think
it's going to be a watch and wait and
see how he makes it through the next
couple of weeks yes i think it certainly
is thank you